you
tournament on where are we uh there we
go
I'm not berserk
it's the hug arena it's bullet chess
it's fast chess okay I don't have to
worry about their dark square Bishop
just play out pon takes I get a nice
center and this game isn't going to end
any time fast Queen b6 is an idea let's
take care first there pawn is pinned
can't move this efore can't do the e4
move just yet I guess we're going to I
was going to play
b5 but they stop that how about just
grab the pun what's wrong with that
whoa they resigned back the tournament
land that was a quick resign twenty-nine
minutes remain
okay two two two we're the only three
that are in here here's a here's a big
fish that didn't take long
let's grab some space I should have
played e4 I would have been dropping
stuff though no let's go fast
let's go fast you're gonna hit that and
it hit me again I like my light-square
control want that diagonal pileup on the
d6 pawn isn't that weak
Bishop f4
okay they're in an uncomfortable pin
I have a better bishop but let's get a
flight square in a bunch of trades
have a very active rook Queen d2 hmm
who's gonna win I have a really strong
queen position yeah I don't know this is
tending towards a draw
hmm they're gonna fix my pawn no they
didn't do that oh yeah they're gonna fix
that pawn this is really weird it's very
tense
I have a passed pawn this is tough now
there Kings going to get in there
let's see defend here their King is very
active I don't have much time
let's take care first hmm I have a past
pun I'm forgetting that I can force
through a past time a past pond
oh I totally missed that move they have
to past ponds ah they got so active with
their King - ah that was a cold shower
right
just one pond move in you're pushing
through with the Queen I like my
position - and that's too bad Queen b6
Bishop to f5 like that's a street killer
- ah the street killer maybe h5 I should
have tried okay
Bishop g6 not so fast
I'm gonna keep that pin get an e5 maybe
I should have done a five instead of
rook so the rook move just take towards
the center okay take that night mmm yeah
why not right now it's tough to hold
that pawn isn't it so I could hit him
again this is winning the pond
let's just bypass that he's still gonna
fall let's take what the clean I wanna
win material and exchange Queens offer a
queen exchange pawn push queen poo that
was a mouse slip they're probably gonna
resign yay or nay now they're playing on
okay maybe they're resigning now playing
on out of momentum maybe okay where's
the mate okay that's another piece okay
they're throwing the kitchen sink at me
Ferraris up their 10 840 4 okay efore I
feel like I already need to do like wild
scholars scholars debate attempts go
scholars mate hunting d5 yeah okay
they're gonna take we're gonna have the
Queen's off no my knight is now gonna
weasel around over here okay push that
night away gonna play Knight there this
is a nice square now my light square
bishop could be an animal maybe he
already is gonna take that pun let's
take here open up the G file definitely
gotta play crazier okay this is getting
broken down real fast
let's undermine that night hmm this is
crumbling fast okay this is matin like
next main to back to tournament land 28
28 8 and then 6 I'm forgetting there's
this little side bar over here okay
let's go with E for my light squared
bishop break the potential pin Bishop g4
Bishop f4 target this now they drop that
okay let's babysit this pawn for just a
second
open file that's flight square and
prepping this move I'm gonna get that
pawn back clean here Queen d2 is my
initial thought but there's nice c4
which is annoying they've been an
awkward pin one thing if they take their
let's throw the knight in the pin and I
got this exchange another pin keep
pressure on the night Bishop takes
Knight hmm let's keep the Queen's on the
board I'll take with
I have a check on f5 Queen here clean
exchange I am up the exchange but
down down timewise very active rook
I've d7 controlled hit the knight who's
now gonna be very active let's get rid
of the block hater push my pawn away
it's keep pushing
check keep pushing I'm promoting soon I
want to keep my rook they were being
sneaky their queen next let's check
that's mate who back to tournament they
were very very fast 25 who someone needs
to knock him out two three and four
fives he's berserk king twenty five
fifteen twelve ten ten who okay
in good field good field oh here's the
leader I was just saying somebody needs
to knock him out maybe I could be the
guy oh no they went with f3 they were
being sneaky isn't this good for me
I think I was saying that in the the
other game isn't this good for me isn't
it good
no turned out to be not so great it's
our other night in a pin clean exchange
go forth at the castle I get the a2 pond
let's do this take him out okay a night
here to hear was my idea but I'd be
losing the exchange
um Bishop here I really piling up on
that but I have it secure I don't know
about that move
hmm it's very weakening probably
shouldn't have done that I'm dropping
that pond I should have pushed him why
didn't I push that pond that's looking
to reposition okay should take that
bishop first maybe thirty two seconds
that's classic time burning stuff okay
not looking too good here
not at all I don't have a good position
with my King either
yeah
there there being a pest there being a
big pest Oh real big pest gonna get my
night okay trading and there the bishop
is really good but I'm completely cut
off their pawns are marching this is too
good
thrown in the towel ouch I guess I'm not
the one to stop him someone else is
gonna have to stop him I tried I tried
stopping the Ferrari but it's too fast
and too strong okay I mean I should have
just gone with the d5 isn't that why I
was doing on these prep moves okay yeah
I lost that's right I lost that passed
pawn definitely lost that passed pawn in
that game all right let's get b5 in and
the secured their pond with the d4 let's
open up the B file mm-hmm I squared
bishop working trade Queens maybe let's
see clean here as well okay I have a
very very active night
very active night soon to be an active
Bishop now he needs to get off of the
seventh rank he's too much yeah my
Knight to c4 I'm glad that the the
Queen's are exchanged makes it a little
bit easier to play or I don't have to
worry about King safety is what I meant
to say should probably look at this move
here huh
hit him with a fork pile up on this pawn
soon to be happening maybe I should have
done this
still Knight here it's hitting the rook
and the pawn on g4 they're gonna hit my
knight now they missed that g4 was
hanging or did they oh boy this is
really dangerous this is oh my goodness
big trouble really big trouble dropping
everything and the clock is not on my
side
oh boy
get active rook do some work some magic
you need to work some magic okay you
need to work some magic do something
dangerous I'm getting mated probably oh
I don't even have any time oof no time
either
o night takes G 4 that was a Poisson
pond ahh
18 minutes remained fancy night man ok I
got to play something more aggressive
than d4 let's try too late to try to get
something more aggressive I'm way way
back in the pack way back in the pack
Knight d4 let's keep this position open
get this this is now a weakness on that
efile oh no exchanges on that one I
think I held my opponent if I do that
hitting the night I was tempted to take
here and destroy the structure let's
just develop though the pressure on this
pawn bishop f3 might be an idea let's
hit this pawn all night here okay that's
a fork let's pick up some material trade
b4 maybe kick the night
now I'm getting this guy they see it
okay they're doing counter-attack but
I'm still on the night
let's recapture they might be resigning
maybe okay let's get to the seventh rank
get rid of their Bishop or just push my
pawn through yeah that's it easier rook
to b8 trading in its mate soon
Bishop passed a block back to tournament
land sir yeah that's not even I'm not
even on the first page you got to get on
the first page before you could read
the UH the leaders get on the first page
first and then we'll talk about leader
stuff later you have to make the first
page get to the first page and only then
will we talk about how far you need to
go let's see one watch out for the
discoveries get out of there
oh that's a freebie they might resign
I'm not giving up I'm not going into the
night quietly I'll go down I'll go down
but I'm not going quietly come on do
something dangerous forks forks are
always dangerous okay hang onto that
pond he's a good man that pond
let's go rook do something mate soon not
quite rook check here kick that night
away okay where is the mate that's a
help mate I needed that back to
tournament no I'm not on the front page
yet it's still a mystery Anton weasel
okay let's do something like this let's
grab some space
all right I'm gonna try to change up how
I would normally play and play more
aggressive that's this is not a good
objectively it's a terrible idea but
we're gonna give it a go and drop a pond
in the process um yeah they could they
could take that pond he really he really
is free he's definitely free okay
there's some weakness there on g3 let's
take there the night's still a nap in my
Bishop's defended I hit that night soon
again watch out for mates watch out for
that mate all right get out of there
Knight got no business being there I
gotta break this down
all right let's trade so much for the
attack right what a beautiful attack
this is men you really varied your style
well and got a beautiful attack right
there well done rook F to Bishop c5 pigs
everybody loves pigs soon to be mate I
think you have to stop my bishop from
getting here they resigned back to
tournament front page
forget about first place yeah I got
first page that's more impressive right
1842 26 no one has even stopped this guy
he's out of control okay I gotta get
this guy back gotta get this guy back
let's do something aggressive d5 f5 get
that F pawn working okay I have a plan
get my Bishop here Queen d7 trade
LightScribe bishops let's throw a jeep
on not so fast though I need some more
support it's not long enough okay this
is helpful actually King f7 is where
you're gonna go it's fire away the fire
way throw some fireworks at your
opponent okay H pawn I need your help if
I'm gonna have any success I need your
help
you need to contribute I maybe I should
have taken their first I want to keep
the Queen's on um I insist I want the
Queen salon I want the Queen still on I
don't know if this is a good idea but
we're gonna give it a go take light
square bishop loo remove that defender
I get in there huh I'm getting into this
oh no right here check and then here
isn't this working
I'm mating are getting the Queen at
least I have Bishop H Bishop h4 I have a
clock advantage you see maybe that's
what maybe that's the idea maybe that is
the idea let's give a check first here
and then push through there probably
close to resigning because I have a time
edge as well or are they okay this
should be close to resigned time finally
get a w-would you okay okay okay okay
now what
hmm pair me up it might be a race for
third can I get on the podium go for the
podium that's the plan
go fishing - don't forget about going
fishing every now and then Queen c7 I
got it got a sneak in a quick kill huh
quick kill every now and then didn't
hurt anybody that did make a lot of
sense Ferrari he is still on fire my
goodness H - bring me some luck would
you no no luck no luck okay alright
they're going to play Knight d5 and it
looks scary I agree but the knight
eventually gets kicked and the bishop is
still hanging
I could take there but I'm not going to
because of this so now they have to
invest some material there Bishop has to
run on the defensive and I'm not done
with my H bond he's brought some luck
last time do something good the pawn is
pinned clean a seven to a 7
rook h2 hmm I'm definitely taking there
seems really active let's go there
and
we might just do this their queen is
restricted now
go here I still have an attack they're
down in time a lot
okay let's just defend they were pre
moving now they can't even do that
that's illegal down on time mate next
they are down
determent 49:29 2826 skies whoo
he's no longer on fire uh-huh
49 29 28 26 where am I 26 I'm one of the
26 okay
upon takes and then I was going to play
Queen check they're launching these
ponds that's some luck with this why not
okay
it's helpful pin this night work with
this guy work with him I could exploit
that pin
Knight takes bishop is dangerous
oh now this is working look at this H
pond he is on a roll H pond is out of
control in all games hang on him he's
past defend my rook if attacked and
develop how's my bishop doing terrible
let's give a check first probably a bad
idea they had this pawn push now we go
here I save my pawn no trade
okay let's go night no they might take I
know let's open up over here 35 seconds
this rook working Queen takes pawn as
well where are the mates they're closed
they're closed by pawn takes there's
made on b3 my queen is in a strong spot
my rook is an animal on the second rank
let's go
take again I get the rook if they take
King takes pawn queen back mate I take
my rook it's me a lot of mates let's
check one of these two that's mate back
to tournament who 5138 30 less than 8
minutes remain
I gotta keep this streak going got to
stay away from these guys less than
eight I'm not getting paired up there we
go
caps are of let's do this no matter what
okay get my bishop out I feel like
moving my Queen out right here right now
Knight f3 on castles Bishop h6 they have
to give the exchange okay so I netted
some material but the attack is
basically gone now or is it H fun so you
have under my queen let's go here g4
I'm h4 and then g4 I need to cover this
square I think yeah I shouldn't have
allowed that double attack against b2
and f2 but my knight is going to
contribute somehow Knight c4 queen is
maybe trapped
soon let's go g4 super super duper
committal but I need to get a little
crazy I need to get a little crazy
all right let's take here and let's pile
up on this soon okay here we go it's not
really working out these attacks here
yeah that's it and that really didn't
work okay
might have something though yeah I
should have done that one move sooner on
the Brooke what's that move about huh
can I do this
oh they got my queen that was the
problem okay
noted I I recognize that now I'm in big
trouble
really big trouble
really really big trouble I need the
throwing checks I need time burners I
definitely need time burners
and take my rook I'm on there Queen I
have a tricky night fortunately
fortunately I have a tricky night Wow
tricky night saves the day what a
beautiful attack well-executed man if I
had time I'd Pat myself on the back for
that terrible attack oh man
awfulness g4 so committal okay let's
grab some space here we go get developed
would you back off I get this in okay
they're grabbing that pun so much for
this this was awful
Queen g3 although I had to watch over
this square get him out of here Queen g3
there could still be some
uncomfortableness with completing their
Queen side
let's stop Knight f5 its Castle I'm
definitely gonna need to castle soon and
defend that pond actually you should
probably defend that pond next time if
you're wise you should defend that pond
okay you're going over here mm-hmm
a 3 and B 4 they should try to get in
that move nice let's stop that move okay
focused on b7 they're gonna give that
Knight up I have a strong Knight again I
could go in here but not really a big
fan of that
stop trickiness and I hear they're gonna
push their pond yeah their night on c2
is a pest definitely a pest I could get
away with that
barely I'm gonna do it though back off
just a hair recapture them on the rook
B for incoming there's still no good
night discovery I don't think at least
recapture at the pond I need to get the
move back
watch out Discovery's now I could take
on b7 let's defend that pond 24 I have a
big-time lead let's back off
get out of trickiness huh I think rook
here would have been a killer and a half
oh boy
running for my life I'm on b7 rook here
I'm on b7 again push this pawn no let's
give a check they're down on time
awful 5750 238 33 minutes remain Oh
again okay I got to get him back is he
gonna move he's definitely gonna move
he's gonna move and he's gonna move fast
nimzo-indian land and I give up the
bishop hair for zero compensation okay
let's get some control over here on the
queenside
move your pieces faster okay am I not
securing this now so I my bishop there
as well um I feel like I have a good
position again my knight should be on d6
they're gonna do a pawn push yeah
strong Knight no no just that huh okay
get that eight three pawn on their night
Hey
and let's put pressure here hmm defend
my pond I need to get activated very
difficult to do very difficult to do
they're going to hunt that pond down
where are they my rook is very active
now very active rooks
clock is not my friend though not my
friend at all huh I could take g 7g to
pawn push next um okay I could take here
and then there there's still make
threats lingering aren't there probably
missing a bunch where oh that's very
helpful or check
want to trade no where's the main here
next who finally back to tournament good
grief
6250 242 my Brooks got activated I don't
think it should have went down like that
one minute remains
6250 242 actually I might sneak away
with third shoe okay let's grab some
space Knight c3 now II four
alright let's get this night out Knight
f3 Bishop to e2 get castled let's see if
I could finish with the W now this one
there's only 36 seconds left
okay they might oh I could possibly get
this they resigned back to term in
seventy one fifty to forty six six
points out that's kind of how that's
gonna be how it ends
seventy one fifty two who Ferrari you
need to slow down man
seventy one fifty four forty six you're
not gonna get paired up again Wow
tough tough tournament how many entered
eighty at least I get on the podium who
it's been a while give me that little
trophy that's a start
it's the hug arena Wow
Ferrari did not have a speed bump until
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen is where
he lost his first game Wow seventy one
final standing seventy one fifty four
forty six and yeah little bit of a
drop-off after that Wow let's see
instead of scrolling now you just click
from page to page here's everyone else
that took part in it thank you guys
could see that on stream
yeah it should be perfect right there
here's everyone else that played what's
going through yeah this is much better
than having to scroll like that good
adjustment 80 players
that's everyone all right to the 80 of
you that took part in this good games Oh
you